[Music]
tim
hmm i know for sure
what were you eating what was that like
a coffee coffee poppy thing
okay i know for sure you have been are
you scooping out of his mouth
okay you have been sent this article a
million times because it's been sent to
me a lot
from you guys because you guys wanted us
to talk about it and it's about
this australian company that has been
accused of appropriating
uh laotian laotian
and thai design oh i saw that it's the
basket chairs right
yeah it's the tables it's like basically
little uh
like tables that you you eat at my
family had one of these yeah
yeah yeah that's pretty cool i read it
is it religious
well they use it in temple from what i
read is that they use it in temples
like they serve food on it yeah i don't
know if it's necessarily religious
um i think it's just it's definitely
just something most
families will have in their house it's
like it's like your little dining room
table you sit on the floor
there it's like you know enough for
maybe four of us to sit around oh that's
pretty spacious
because it looked like a like a side
table like smaller no no
photos it looks kind of small to me no
no it's like you could sit
with like you could sit around like with
like four homies and eat yeah and then
is it low enough where you have to sit
on the floor sitting on the floor oh
okay you know what's crazy
is with bamboo you could make a hat you
could make a
table you could make a chair you could
make weapons
you make a house yeah literally i watch
that [ __ ] all day long on youtube
like and you could eat bamboo like you
could take the roots out of that [ __ ]
like
everything you can grow it dude if
anybody ever appropriates white trash
culture and eats off of a microwave box
i'm gonna be [ __ ] pissed microwave
box
yeah you could you know the box you get
the microwave in it can be like a little
coffee table
yeah true you use cardboard box on top
you eat it on top you get a hungry man
dinner yeah you can eat a tv dinner on
top of it yep true
you just can't spell any drinks on it no
no no that'll [ __ ] the whole table up
dude come on yeah a lot of people tagged
me in this
um i was kind of going both ways on it
like i understand
both ways well because look i i
definitely understand why people are mad
because this company like stole
something that was like like
traditionally from like like a
a specific culture right like type loud
culture
and they um didn't give any credit they
were calling it like the malibu table or
something
like that they weren't informing anyone
of where it came from or whatever right
that's one of the main reasons why
people were really pissed off
the fact that they're selling it for
like 400 or 300 something dollars
right and then when traditionally or
like a regular one is like 30 to 100
so a lady in in thailand weaved it and
then sold it for like two bucks and then
that company is basically selling it for
like 400. oh so they're claiming that
they're getting their tables produced in
indonesia
and they are handmade in indonesia so
they did admit to that and
but still people oh the other thing
that's really really controversial
about this that people are very upset
about is the fact that once they got
called out for it they started deleting
and blocking people
deleting comments and a lot of people
found that to be
like adding fuel to the fire and
disrespect because they're like why are
you silencing our voices
they're not engaging in a solution oh so
they didn't um
respond in a way that seemed like they
gave a [ __ ]
well they did give an apology and people
are calling it an empty apology this is
what they said they said thank you for
your comments on our malibu coffee table
we are an australian-based small
family-run business and our products are
produced in likewise small family
businesses in indonesia we are sorry
if we have offended anyone and and
cultural appropriation is the last thing
we want to do
thank you for letting us know the origin
of this style whilst we do not
have the original and our tables are
handmade in indonesia we appreciate your
feedback and we will have the
origin of this style stated on our
website the malibu style name reflects
our coastal branding
like all our like all our products
and the size and craftsmanship is very
different to the original as
as it is made to a coffee table size
we only want to show respect and support
for all cultures and communities and
certainly do not aim to offend anyone
is that table like the minute you see it
you go okay that's
thai inspired because i see i just see a
regular coffee table
yeah well for me when someone tagged me
i was like that looks like a tie table
it was like the table i had in my like
family's living room right
so i understand that part of the outrage
but at the same time another part of me
was kind of like
if if bougie white
people want to pay 300 dollars from
other
like boozy white people for what they
thought was just a random table
then like then and we all know where to
get the real [ __ ]
from then you don't know the history tim
right because are you even serious right
now aren't they aren't they paying to
not know the history well you know
because that's the thing right it's like
if they if they want to pay
if they want to sell to each other these
like ridiculously priced tables then
apartments like let them do it right
because i was i kind of got in the
mindset of like
you know growing up in la we know where
to get the really good
uh elote right the real mexican corn
from the elotero man right
but it's like then you got these fancier
restaurants that have kind of
put their own kind of elote on their
menus it's like that's like 20 bucks for
like their own variation which isn't
nearly as good
so a part of me was like it feels the
same way you know what i'm saying if
they've been with what
like mexicans like you know like in
indigenous mexicans they make
like hand make watches which are sandals
like three feet
and a lot of high fashion designers and
brands like they
take those designs and make their own
version and sell them for like thousands
of dollars
i think their outrage though is the fact
that because it's from
it's very sacred to the culture from
what i understand the reason why people
are upset about this is because of the
fact that this is an item that's very
sacred to the culture it's also from the
culture and like for someone else to
take that design steal it make it their
own and then pay like
charge up the ass for it it's just kind
of like what the [ __ ]
like you're just blatantly i kind of get
it because
um so quicksilver their design
is inspired by a japanese family crest
right or like
so it's a little bit adjusted but then
when i think there are just us brands or
or companies that would take family
crests
and then they would just duplicate it
without
you know they don't they don't change
anything and then they use it as a
design or whatever
it was always weird to me because i'm
like uh
that was someone's family's last name
that you just took
it's weird because i don't i don't know
i don't own it but i've seen my family
quest
in a lot of different places really yeah
it's common and then like so
back then the way that they did it in
japan was like your family crest was
your
company logo it was like it was like you
know whatever
your family built like let's say your
family builds uh
chairs right or it's a whatever you have
your stamp
so they know that uh joe's family built
it or whatever
and so if you do use it as a company
logo that concept
has been there for hundreds of years but
then when it's
not used correctly it's kind of a joke
but i don't
get offended i'm kind of like oh that's
weird yeah see that's the thing it's
like i
i get i get where the uh the outrage
comes from because it's like just give
give credit where credit is due and i
understand it especially when you know
everybody
is influencing each other and kind of
like
um learning from each other on how to
create new [ __ ]
i get where people really want to make
sure you just you remember where it
comes from you know what i'm saying like
i get that so i have a lot of family
from philadelphia and recently i me and
nicki were ordering sushi and i was i
was given what they called a
philadelphia rule
and uh i gotta tell you i was pretty
[ __ ] pissed because philadelphia
cheese
yeah because this what uh who does the
sushi
is it japanese right mm-hmm yeah so they
uh appropriated
philadelphian cheese and yeah was i
[ __ ]
livid is it appropriation when they're
using the same product
in it excuse me is it appropriations
philadelphia they're wrong
didn't they make the table out of the
same stuff did i know did they i don't
know did they i don't know did they i
don't know did they
i don't want people making it i don't
know i want to ask my parents i'm like
dad do you care about this unless you my
dad says yeah let us know yeah
it's weird because it's not all one
people right like for example
um so in japan like they don't really
have this concept
of cultural appropriation but i know
that white people
are hypersensitive about putting on the
kimono or like doing things
because of what people back at home
might say
but like out in japan everyone likes
when a black white whoever comes over
and puts on the clothes they almost want
you to like you want to do this thing
and walk around
you want to walk around wear the [ __ ]
hat be a ninja pretend you're a [ __ ]
ninja dude i wore it proudly in a jk
party video
where i played the role of tom cruise
from
the last samurai and because i couldn't
have been able to portray tom cruise in
last samurai if i didn't have the kimono
that's you making a statement bro you
know what i'm saying bro but that's true
i did feel really odd like when we went
to japan before the kimonos i was like i
don't want people to get offended by me
trying to like
show appreciation of the culture same
with in korea
we wore it the hambach or whatever i was
like oh no
i blinked on the name yes the hambach
same thing but it was like the people
like the tourism board
of south korea like put this [ __ ] on
literally it took us to go put it up
it's like where do you draw the line
of like appreciation and appropriation
like i think
sometimes it's difficult to know what is
the right thing to do
yeah i think it's a matter of
perspective because it's like like like
yeah countries like
japan and korea like we're bringing up
as examples it's like over there they
don't
see appropriation like that and then
like over here in the states it's like
you have like melting pots like la where
we
all feel like this sensitivity towards
appropriation but if you go to like
bum [ __ ] kansas then it's like you know
then
but we deem them racist for thinking
that it's okay to do these kinds of
appropriation stuff and they're not like
so i
always feel like the melting pot concept
is kind of self-sabotaging
and that it feeds us this like a pro
appropriation thing
cause like okay when i was at salt lake
city right and then like they're kind of
like
late to the game when it comes to
multiculturalism and i was in salt lake
city
and i saw this chinese restaurant and it
was literally
a chinese dude with slatted eyes and a
rice [ __ ] hat
like this yeah as a logo with [ __ ]
chopsticks
and it was like ciao something yeah and
i'm like oh
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me bro
like what the [ __ ]
it was mind-blowing you you found
offense to that
i was shocked i didn't i didn't think
that [ __ ] still existed
and obviously it's asians working the
restaurant right
they're just playing into the role of
what they think white people would like
but then at the same time i'm just kind
of confused because i'm like
they need to make a living they're just
kind of playing this thing
right they're marketing yeah but then
but then it's like where do you draw the
line
like i ain't gonna step in and tell
these guys it wasn't a restaurant full
of white people it was chinese people
right it it's just branded hella like
racist i saw this
maybe you're thinking about the one that
i saw which was like ching chong
something it was like that and then they
were actually
asian-owned restaurant and they were
like guys like we're
like can like we can't be racist against
ourselves people even took that and they
were like
no no like why are you perpetuating more
of this so then there's also
anger there yeah like i think the anger
comes from
like yeah they say we can't be racist to
ourselves but then it's like
when you make not asian people think
it's okay
to say it then it's it's like a problem
right like if they're like oh no that's
fine i'm eating that ching chong's
and it's like hey bro it's not cool or
something i don't remember
yeah i think that's you and i think and
so i i get it
you know where it's like like let's say
someone took my mom's
recipe for these little curry puffs she
does she sells them for like two three
dollars each which is like
such a good deal someone took the recipe
and was bigger company took it was
selling them for like twenty dollars
um and i so i get where i would be like
hey what the [ __ ] bro this is my mom's
recipe
yeah and you guys are calling them you
know tiffany de reale's curry puffs
without giving credit
but would you be would you feel okay
with
if that major company paid your mom
and it's and she's the one supplying the
curry puffs
would that be okay like where where is
it because i'm trying to understand like
with this black
salt company scandal here a lot of
people
are upset that they've been they're
being silenced but when i was trying to
look into like okay what actions do they
want
it seems to me as if they just want them
to completely stop selling
this table all together where i'm like
okay
i could understand that but then if they
were going to sell this table to begin
with would it be okay if they were
sourcing it
from laos or thailand right and
and then making their profit because
that that seems to be like what can
like virtually maybe they got to get a
thai ceo or some [ __ ] yeah
get a thai ceo so now it's a thai
company and now it's okay i guess and if
you want to buy it you better pass a dna
test that's what i think
and uh because i think that's important
that you're not buying it to make fun
of them you're buying it because you
want to use this table yeah so then i
did read that a lot of people are saying
at least for the consumers that they
were like listen like don't buy from
this company
just go and buy it from the source and
then that's okay but does the source
have free shipping
no probably not they don't have a coupon
code either it just
it just sounds like people are trying to
figure out how to deal with
exploitation which has been happening
within all races yeah and it doesn't
make it okay but like i mean like think
about
even the brands that we wear like the
overpriced shoes that
are [ __ ] made or the phones and the
laptops and everything that we have like
they're made extremely cheap i love that
we're asking these questions but i wish
we were asking questions about supply
chain
like honestly who's making this [ __ ]
where in china are they making it
who what kind of slave is making it like
that all is swept
under a rug that is a corporate rug by
the way that is fed into by our own
media and so
you know that that's it's a cynical
thing to say and a really nice
indian corporate rug too i know right
it's just ironic because i see nike talk
about all kinds of [ __ ] and then we find
out about
the chinese muslims who are literally
making their [ __ ] so and they're forced
to and they go on trains and they get
killed
so free labor it's a big [ __ ] scam
that the supply chain stuff
but then everyone you know corporate
driven is pissed at
the top of the foam like they're not
looking at the iceberg in the water
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and around yeah you can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you